but they were never hot and then [ __ ]
hilarious and filmed as [ __ ] and she had
it all and then this guy was also a very
good looking dude but he used to just
like scream or call her dumb tell her
she's not funny wow that he that
whenever she goes out and makes all this
noise that she's embarrassing
and so she just kept getting smaller and
smaller and smaller so he would gaslight
her all the [ __ ] time wow yeah and
then uh she used her she left him
because her dad overheard
her sister talking to um her boyfriend
about it in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast for
the very specific topic today i brought
two of the biggest tards i know
tards as in turds not [ __ ] because
that is offensive that's you can't cross
that line never i've never ever said the
word [ __ ] right [ __ ] here we go
no seriously you guys shouldn't use that
word i only found out not too long ago
that wasn't um oh yeah how long ago
david
how long ago was this timeline what
happened how did you find out i wanted
to start eight years ago
well i used to get arguments about it
because i didn't think that you because
you can't say the word [ __ ] for
anything you can't say it about an
object you can't even though it's an you
can actually use it to say what about a
small animal what about flame retardant
you can't say that either because i used
to think it was called flame [ __ ]
and somebody corrected what do you say
flame autistic oh that's
flame on especially
making a comeback though i hear way more
people using this i mean back stand up a
lot
i think i don't know
i heard uh people on cnn use it you know
you heard nick you see that word
dude it's making a comeback bro you know
like like clothing styles will come back
retards making a comeback it's it's like
it's like the 90s right like all the
trends in the 90s or the early 2000s
it's coming back i just remember target
but do you remember that period of the
internet where everything became hyper
corrective and i'm not i'm not making a
statement about whether you should or
shouldn't say it but even when people
used to say it all the time they would
look at you as if you were the biggest
bastard they've ever seen in their life
they're like why would you ever use that
word it's like dude i grew up with you
you said it all the time i didn't know
that it was cancelable you should have
gave me a heads up you [ __ ] dick yeah
right this whole beginning part so i'm
just gonna chop this up yeah and i'm
canceled we're all cancer i think we're
all cancelled all canceled on on reddit
somebody told me they they sent me this
[ __ ] well they were kind of laughing
about it but there was this clip of me
telling meryl that i'm a puncher in her
mouth
as a joke yeah you know because that's
how we [ __ ] around we've been doing that
since we first we all say that to our
significant others all the time i beat
the [ __ ] out of my
girlfriend it's sick
and we laugh after we hold our bellies
and we go
beating the [ __ ] out of your girlfriend
allegedly
allegedly allegedly so
this court case or these allegations
have been out for a very long time but i
didn't know that people or the companies
like disney and everybody else were
still quote-unquote canceling johnny
depp because even when this first came
out
years ago it was like two years ago
everybody knew that she was kind of
batshit crazy specifically because they
were like i think eyewitness accounts
and that you know him getting his finger
chopped off but now johnny depp is suing
her for like 50 million dollars right
because of all the jobs he's lost
specifically uh parts of the caribbean
they didn't want to do the caribbean bro
price the caribbean yeah caribbean i
don't know yeah
i think it's caribbean i don't want to
get cancelled dude
that's the clip
oh my god he said caribbean people in
the crib
what was that jamaican or something oh
no i don't care we don't know [ __ ]
don't cancel me i just know there's a
pirate with a bunch of octopus face
that's all i know yeah davey wayne's
dave that was david
damon
[Music]
how many uh pirate movies right there
too many like four or five i only saw
one they're fun though they're pretty
too many what like when i was it came
out it came out in the seventh grade
when i was like yeah so it's like oh
when i was in seventh grade it was fun
yeah yeah but after two i'm good it's
been around for that [ __ ] long yeah
middle school i agree 2001
ish yeah around that
no probably a little later than that
that's what i was hoping he was making a
[ __ ] ton of money off of that cause he
was also a part of the harry potter
series apparently too which i didn't
know where he was the griswold biswald
one or whatever the fantastic we know
what are you talking about it's like
henry griswold's secrets fantastic child
beast or something you know this is
excellent that's gonna get him canceled
yeah yeah keep talking [ __ ] yeah
you know what i'm saying dude
yeah so he he's getting worried so he's
sorry he's doing her for 50 million
dollars right and then she's trying to
counter sue him
yeah i don't is she i think she's trying
to countersue him maybe but that's dumb
but the crazy thing about this court
case is how much evidence is stacked
against her it's unreal it's really bad
it's like there's and also the clips
dude some of the virus there was one we
that me and tiff were watching last
night and it was i guess he was like uh
the front desk guy that worked at the
apartment that they lived in or
something like that he was like the the
floor guy and he's in the car doing the
he's getting cross-examined and he's
like hitting this vape and he starts
driving as he's like answering questions
but
this clip went viral because they were
asking like did you observe
any like marks on her face or anything
out of the ordinary and he's like this
mexican dude he's like
he's like no i'm not looking at people
to see if they got marks on her face
like what kind of [ __ ] piece this was
four years ago
i don't remember he's like i don't know
and he's like god okay and then they
leave and everyone's like tripping out
but he's literally blowing smoke out of
his nose hitting the vape while they're
crossing
so he zoomed into court yeah i guess a
couple of people zoomed in
so this guy is literally in his car and
he's vaping and he's driving as he's
doing it which is illegal he's like
reversing his [ __ ] yeah he's committing
a crime it is
the funniest
i don't know who the [ __ ] she hired as
her lawyer
they're trash they're bombing it so bad
the funny i think to me the funniest
thing was when the lawyer stood up in
confidence saying my my uh like whatever
client amber heard she had to hide her
bruises with this specific makeup and it
wasn't even made during the time that
she was supposed to use my god so the
company the company who created the
makeup said uh that wasn't made at that
time we just made that recently
what kind of trap is this a public
defender don't you have money don't you
have money dude did you see that when he
asked the question and he objects his
own question did you see that
what's up
objection hearsay he goes you asked the
question
[Music]
[ __ ] you're right but also it's like she
has no ground like she has no evidence
she she's clearly like mentally ill like
she she clearly has a personality
disorder you know so all they can really
do is just like try to
uh all the witnesses that go up and for
johnny depp all they can really do is
like question their credibility that's
the only thing they could do yeah and
it's like it's not it's they're arguing
semantics they even brought a
psychologist to go ahead she was dope
and assess amber her and she was ripping
into not even ripping in just giving her
like a psychoanalysis of her like her
tendency to like lie and exaggerate she
was [ __ ] on the lawyers yeah it was
crazy they couldn't clap back they could
they and all the claims that she would
say they just they couldn't they had no
rebuttal yeah because they probably know
the lawyers probably know she's crazy
too they do know yeah for sure but i
can't believe they're so bad like dude
you know how bad they are they're
terribly bad i could do a better job i
don't know the law i could do a better
job
my client ashley amber
wait what's your name
what's your name [ __ ] yeah
what did they what else did they do they
had the the whole thing where um the
poop amber turd chamber
and guess what she went to coachella
that weekend she left [ __ ] in the bed
and johnny depp's mother died that
weekend
damn dude and then she's [ __ ] in the
casket
did you did you hear like his whole
story of like him explaining what
happened it was really [ __ ] sad well
he was like she left to coachella and
they had an argument and then she [ __ ]
the bed after coachella or before
coachella as she was leaving oh on the
way out she's like
then i gotta i gotta handle some biz see
you later shit's in the bed and he's
like you know what you're gonna stay
here i'm gonna handle my [ __ ] i'm gonna
wait for you to go to coachella and then
when you go to coachella i'm gonna
gather all my valuables all of my
favorite things that i need from the
house and then just
remove myself from the situation and
then the guy that i guess runs his house
or cleans his house or something took a
picture of the the piece of [ __ ] on the
bed
and then was like right now is not a
good time for you to come because
there's a piece of [ __ ] on your side of
the bed
and then obviously we all know that she
tried to like blame it on
their four pound yorkies okay it was
just crazy was it a big old dookie it
was a picture honestly it was kind of
small for a human being but it was
definitely big bigger than a dog [ __ ] no
that's that's human dukes you guys saw
the pictures oh yeah yeah hell would you
you don't like scat [ __ ]
yeah right
let me send it to you right now yeah i
cannot see that that was human poop that
was definitely human poop like she cut
it off quick man
sniffed it she was like
there was this one funny clip something
about a throat joke and yeah yeah yeah
he was like i want to do something to
your throat but not painful it's like
he's like why does he have to read this
we all know what you mean
dude if we anybody had to read their
text messages guilty of whatever crime
you'd be doing objection hearsay
they had a compilation of the uh of
amber heard's lawyer consistently keep
on saying objection and hearsay over and
over and then johnny that would talk he
goes well
no okay
he was doing a stand-up set he's hello
yeah he was he was really funny like he
had the crowd busting up multiple times
i was like this was charismatic as [ __ ]
how could you not laugh though because
it's the most ridiculous thing i've ever
seen in my life yeah it's to the point
where people forgot about the kids in
ukraine like nobody's nobody cares
you're crazy we're about to get nuked
we're about to get nuked and people are
like yo what's up with this even
watching this trial bro you don't think
he got the subtitles and he's like yo
his amber heard [ __ ] it's crazy
he's like
my god this is crazy that's why they're
losing the war bro he's too busy
watching the trial do you see that uh
the compilation clip of putin trying to
shake everybody's hands that they keep
dissing him yeah that's just hella funny
dude nobody wants to shake his hands
different russian bro and russia like
he'll be like this and every diplomat
just goes
oh really like this the whole time yeah
i wonder why that is happening i think
they're afraid he's gonna kill him
because was like poison yep man read my
[ __ ] mind dude
is that how he kills people i know but
he was he was like special forces and he
has killed people he was part of the kgb
or some [ __ ] there was a guy in in that
was from russia but he fled to england
or something like because he was a
a one of his rivals and he put nerve
like a nerve agent on his doorknob and
the guy like touched it and like i think
he died or almost died yeah i heard
about that so that's the scene you'll
[ __ ] with some poison
see that's why nobody wants to shake his
[ __ ] hand they're too scared yeah i
guarantee you he's trying to shake their
head and kill him what about one of
these they just give him like an elbow
he probably don't do that he's not going
to miss it no he's rushing he's not
going to risk that [ __ ] [ __ ] no bro
missing something would you how hot how
hot is amber heard to you scale of one
to ten i i i don't know she's she's
gotta i haven't really seen her whole
set up you know what i mean but like
sure she's her she's pretty she has a
really pretty face how much would you
deal with for that prettiness no i would
not deal with that like it would just
have to be like a one-time like she has
no gag reflex she was crazy and then it
would have to be like that's the rule it
would have to be like uh yeah for sure
and then uh there's gotta be like
evidence so like because she could say
some crazy [ __ ] so it's gotta be like yo
we're gonna film this
are you cool with that and she's like
yeah we're cool with that okay cool and
then like it needs to be documented so
i'm saying she says it's set up already
she's so crazy that you have to have
like your ducks in a row
she's so nuts they're both recording
each other arguing so they could use it
later on just in case and she's
literally screaming at him like go ahead
johnny go tell the whole world i dare
you nobody's gonna [ __ ] did you
listen to the other audio recordings
like after like he pun she punched him
in the face in like the bathroom
argument or something like that the
audio recordings are crazy because
i think their argument initially was
about like how
he was trying to get some space from her
because she was just like yelling all
the time and he's like look i need to
come back
i need to remove myself from the
situation i can't be sitting here and
arguing with you fighting all the time
and it was so funny he used like a
boxing analogy he's like even in a
12-round fight there's one minute breaks
in between each round he's like i gotta
take my break in between each round i go
to the bathroom and kind of collect
myself and then she's like just run away
from all your problems because she's
clearly like at a point where she
doesn't it sounds like even in that
recording she doesn't take any
responsibility for her actions like
she's any time he says you punched me in
the face and she goes come on johnny i
did not punch you i hit you but i didn't
punch you and he goes
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you talking
about bro
i've met a couple of girls who were like
that
i don't know if i know any guys are like
that cause i feel like guys wouldn't do
that maybe maybe they have i don't know
but it's hard to get their own ways you
know yeah guys have their own type of
crazy but like that there's that weird
thing of when you see somebody who
no matter what they could spin it and
they turn it on you like they're always
constantly gaslighting that's a
personality disorder isn't it it's
straight up is dude it's like they call
it bpd it's i forgot what it stands for
those are tight yeah you got baby do you
have that bbd but like those people are
the hardest to help because they don't
take any sense of personal
responsibility at all so even if you try
to therapize them because they don't see
fault in themselves they can't accept
change right so for somebody like that
you could see no matter what he does
she's always the victim her life could
be at the peak because it's amber her i
think she's like a model she's married
she was married to [ __ ] johnny depp
she's loaded rich as [ __ ] but even then
no matter how great her life is there's
always something to complain about
something because if there's not trouble
or problems then she's not happy you
know what she asked for post divorce and
i think they were talking about it today
they were saying that she wanted 14
million dollars
tax-free
after the divorce from giant debt
tax-free tax-free i was like you could
do that
you could just ask for tax-free money
are you the catholic church
and they were interviewing uh i think
their financial
advisor that was handling the divorce
and he was explaining to them like this
is what were some of the terms that she
wanted and i i don't even know how the
[ __ ] that works i didn't know that was
even possible yeah but my question is
how did she even hook up with how long
was she dating elon musk for and what
the [ __ ] was that like i didn't even
know she was with she was also about
dating james franco or something
apparently he's supposed to hit the
stand was that you though yeah yeah
i'm gonna cross-examine him for some
[ __ ] because i feel like he was a part
like i said i read this very loosely so
correct me if i rock once again this is
not a new source so [ __ ] you
you're talking [ __ ] baby come on yeah so
james franco this guy calls a [ __ ] at
the beginning of the episode
i did not i said i used to say it and i
don't say it anymore you [ __ ]
so
this podcast is sponsored by better help
my friends are you dealing with a lot of
stress well guess what there's so many
different indicators of it like
headaches teeth grinding and so much
more even sleeping too little well guess
what my friends have you tried therapy
stress shows up in all kinds of ways and
in a world that's telling you to do more
sleep less and grind all the time here's
your reminder to take care of yourself
do less and maybe try some therapy and
do it with better help because better
help is the [ __ ] i've been using it for
a very long time and they have been a
long time sponsor because i really do
[ __ ] with them better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress i've
been using better health for a long time
my friends and talking to my therapist
helps me out i do it two to three times
a month and guess what it is a necessity
if i'm gonna take care of myself
physically i'm i'ma take care of myself
mentally genius brain listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius this is cnn yeah
cnn but they um they said that they're
gonna cross-examine him or something i
don't know the exact lawyer terms
because he has something to do that
sounds right that's hearsay doug yeah
objection doug yeah we should be able to
object in real life you know what i mean
like objective [ __ ] you could i guess
objection what's what you're gay
objection your honor i'm not gay
what are you talking to
remember her too she was a she was a
model
i think
i think she was like a supermodel i
thought she's an actress
i don't know what she's i remember that
[ __ ] in zombieland she's no she don't
care to look it up she was a zombieland
that's the only movie i know her from
she ends on me and i remember she was
the [ __ ] in the beginning that that get
turns into a zombie and tries to kill
jesse eisenberg i don't damn he kills
her in her bathroom stuff
i remember really that is her huh that's
her claim to fame i like how she also
imitates everything he wears yeah that's
crazy this is the weirdest thing he he
wears like a tie with the suit she has a
tie with the suit he has his hair tied
but she has her hair how does she how
does she know what he's going to wear
hey
why did
yeah
she
[ __ ]
she [ __ ] on beds dude yeah i don't know
i can't when is she going to hit the
stand i can't wait for her to like get
cross-examined and ask her like
so do you really think that that [ __ ] on
the bed was
she's going to start crying
of course she's already crying bro
because this man like the emotional
abuse but people like her are very very
manipulative man and like
i don't i only know of like one
maybe two but this is the one that i'm
reminded of the most i've talked about
this on the podcast where like there are
certain people who are just so
manipulative and they kind of have a
control over the guys that they're with
100 they can just say and do [ __ ]
whatever and there's only two people i
met one person i can't mention the other
one there was a girl who used to date
this guy in high school this guy was a
[ __ ] maniac i remember in high school
he uh he dropped out he came on campus
because he was dating this girl named
and we just see this full walk up and i
remember because i was at my locker and
i see this fool just broken up kind of
with his homies you know the gang that
he was in not even causing his national
gang he walked in there in the bloods
walks over to her
socks her and breaks her [ __ ] nose oh
my god on campus and he just walks the
[ __ ] off security campus didn't do [ __ ]
because you know they're all strapped up
so it's like what the [ __ ] are you gonna
do so that [ __ ] maniac later on i
find out he's in jail um but what
happened was he dated somebody else
after that so this girl was also one of
you know you know those girls who like
to date like bad boys even though she
grew up in a very very nice household so
this girl was like this uh catholic girl
right and she loved kicking it with like
a bunch of like hood dudes and i only
know she's not my friend i only knew of
her because she was always trying to
[ __ ] some of the dudes in the crew yeah
so she ends up
dating somebody in that group doesn't
work out really well she tries to do the
opposite and date somebody really nice
like a geeky geeky asian kid yeah this
geeky asian kid obviously is super happy
to date this girl right because let's be
real you're a little batty she's batty
yeah yeah
you know yeah yeah she didn't have a gag
reflex she probably yeah she got an
amber herd style yeah i mean no tears
with that deep bro
you know what i mean
have a conversation it doesn't break eye
contact doesn't blink never blinks she
just likes to come and [ __ ] moistens
her eyes with it she was very well known
for these type of skills
sorry brother
brother yeah she's smashed
um
this guy obviously can't handle this
girl very well right
it's not he's not used to this [ __ ]
if johnny depp can't handle this chick
yeah this poor asian kid was not well
equipped so in high school no [ __ ]
way absolutely not so he breaks up with
her but obviously and this is my my i'm
speculating this right because in her
mind she's doing this little nerd dweeb
a [ __ ] favor like i'm dating you i'm
sucking your [ __ ] blowing his back in
there
she ends up dating that guy that sucks
that girl in the nose right
so she tells him that guy that that
nerdy asian kid raped her oh
[ __ ] true [ __ ] story oh no true
[ __ ] story
tells this dude and this guy is a
volatile human being yeah yeah obviously
he walks on campus breaks the girl's
nose and just walks off yeah so
this guy
uh this poor kid finds his fool
at his house they're gonna die with that
girl and his gang walks up execution
style murders him right on the spot on
his drone what like a crazy person [ __ ]
so they find out obviously the cops get
involved because you don't just murder
somebody like that and this is a
just a sweet sweet kid that just [ __ ]
with the wrong girl
he gets murdered because this girl lied
about her being sexually assaulted by
the other dude you might even be able to
find a news article about this [ __ ] this
pretty some crazy [ __ ] wow bro so he
he dies
everybody there gets like 20
i think 20 20 ish that girl's in jail
for life because she was the ring master
oh so they proved that she's the one
that did that yeah they had i'm pretty
sure they found i don't know the exact
details because you know this was pretty
sad it was like they probably found text
messages [ __ ]
but
could you imagine how [ __ ]
manipulative that [ __ ] girl was to
get this person killed just because her
[ __ ] feelings were hurt because she
felt that you know this geek shouldn't
dump me i'm the one doing him a [ __ ]
favor so when i see that amber herd case
it reminds me of that that that's why
that's why this is kind of good because
like it's finally shining a light on
these kind of situation because this is
a thing that it's not like
obviously not every woman is like this
or whatever it's probably a minority but
like there are crazy ass [ __ ] like
that that will cause true obsession 100
and and his mental illness let's be real
yeah yeah that's what it really is yeah
this is like this isn't a normal woman
this is a crazy individual we all know a
couple stories
like from people like we we have we all
have a mutual friend who had an
ex-girlfriend who would do this type of
[ __ ] and just kind of play with his
emotions and string out their
relationship and be really toxic and do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] constantly like this is
not something that
that is like new this is stuff that
we've seen that we've observed right and
maybe through other people like i'm
thankfully lucky enough to not have to
deal with any of that [ __ ] but we all
know people that have and sure they've
they've taken some damage from that time
but what's cool what's good about this
is because like even like johnny depp
just based off the accusation he lost so
much 100 percent like he lost a lot like
10 million yeah a gang of money no more
movies like a lot of work
based on just the accusation yeah so the
fact that like now it's like there's
some redemption it like kind of shines a
light like okay maybe the next time
we'll take it case by case and we'll
just look at this [ __ ] or give it some
[ __ ] time before you drop the guy
like wait for the facts to come out just
wait let's figure it out let's see what
happens like immediately the rumors came
out and the company goes [ __ ] you yeah
that's what i'm saying that's crazy
bill burr was talking about his podcast
about this uh case in particular and he
was saying like
the least they could do is if there's a
real legit investigation or there's real
accusations don't release the person's
name until the the trial has gone
through yeah and there is a verdict
that's what they do in ireland really
yeah because i remember conor mcgregor
was in trouble like there was like a
rape accusation and they they wouldn't
release the guy they knew it was like a
high profile person but i irish law is
like they they do that they won't
release anything until they kind of
figure it out which is smart makes
[ __ ] sense because looking for stuff
like this right cause like
public court like pure public court is
the most vicious thing ever they hear
anything that's remotely negative about
you and they [ __ ] run with it and it
could be something crazy like this is
the most craziest thing ever like this
guy gets his fingers sliced off can you
see the picture wow it was disgusting it
was gross his finger gets sliced off
she's beating on this dude she shits in
his [ __ ] bed is a maniac and then all
of a sudden she goes he hit me they go
well doesn't matter what you say
you beat amber heard but on the flip
side to play devil's advocate is this
not one of the best trials ever bro oh
i'm very grateful for this
oh i'm very grateful the amount of
entertainment i've gotten from this is
actually ridiculous i was trying to stay
away from this [ __ ] i was like i don't
want to hear this ball i don't want to
hear another thing i don't want to like
see none of this but then
once i heard amber turd hashtag amber
turner
i was like your boy is it dawg did you
really [ __ ] the bed i gotta get to the
bottom of this i gotta find out did this
[ __ ] really [ __ ] the bad dude amber
turd that's [ __ ] dope dude that's
fire for her whole life that's what's up
amber turd you think she can turn it
around do you think she can turn it
around absolutely not and whoever
[ __ ] dates this girl after you're a
[ __ ] psychopath absolutely you're
somebody will somebody will who do you
think is going to be some dude will i
don't know what what high celebrity
[ __ ] some people like crazy people
though yeah they just want to get a
taste they want to see what the hype's
about you know i could probably change
her do i know there's like so you know
when you kind of look back and you
you've talked to like so many friends
about these crazy relationships that
they've been in like i haven't been in
any of these types but i've always heard
stories about stuff like that like i
heard so one of my homegirls dated this
guy
which we never [ __ ] liked we never
liked this dude specifically because he
pointed at me this guy dude so i'm not
going to say her name it rhymes with
biff
okay okay
i can show you the dms the other day she
was like congrats on the store in hawaii
i was like great you're invited but not
nick
to wait outside
and tiffany agreed she was like okay
yeah she was like
it was great but i heard this
i heard the story well that story i
didn't hear the story it was this person
that we knew that was within this small
little group
that we had and you know like it kind of
sucks when you're in a relate when
you're
in a friendship with somebody and they
date somebody you [ __ ] hate because
yeah all the gatherings this
[ __ ] is there and so the first
kill yeah the first thing that we
noticed that she's super goofy hella
[ __ ] funny whenever he's around she's
super just hanging i hate that that's
the worst and so first it was really
weird she would just not say anything
and we're like hey are you okay what's
going on and she goes no no i'm just
really tired or whatever but every time
they came out
or some [ __ ] they would always fight or
or about something right and so after
they broke up she basically told us that
he was like super abusive uh very
[ __ ] controlling and then he didn't
like the fact that whenever they went
out she was like the star because she
was that [ __ ] funny she was hilarious
so everybody wanted to talk to her he
didn't like guys approaching her girls
it didn't [ __ ] matter and he
specifically had a problem with me but
i've known this girl since i was five
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
so you stabbed him in the face with a
pencil david is
we did a boxing match and it was with
only lips and i was like the first
person to fall in love is gay
guess what he was
hell gay this was like i can't fight you
no more bro i'm trying to put a ring on
it
i gotta marry you dog
bruh
oh yeah yeah but this dude
i love happy endings yeah that's the
best that's a good one yeah but this guy
she told us that um
like for example
he didn't like her getting attention so
that's why she would always like make
herself smaller and smaller because if
if
i don't know whether it's be i don't i
don't even i think now as an older
person i kind of want to know what the
[ __ ] he went through to kind of try to
control
his partner like that because number one
she's the sweetest person ever yeah you
know what i mean yeah and not only was
she super pretty she was very
charismatic which i don't you don't i
honestly i never got to see a lot and a
lot of girls that i knew they were
either really hot and they were kind of
funny but they were never hot and then
[ __ ] hilarious and dope as [ __ ] and
she had it all and then this guy was
also a very good looking dude but he
used to just like scream or call her
dumb tell her she's not funny wow that
he that whenever she goes out and makes
all this noise that she's embarrassing
and so she just kept getting smaller and
smaller and smaller so he would gaslight
her all the [ __ ] time wow yeah and
then uh she used she left him because
her dad overheard
her sister talking to um her boyfriend
about it and he in the house because her
sister was [ __ ] mad and her dad's on
the other line so dad was in the house
and then i don't know how he overheard
but he overheard it he goes over there
goes ballistic on the guy starts banging
on his [ __ ] door telling him to come
out that's a good parent after that they
broke up because he was [ __ ] scared
for life her dad was huge by the way oh
really gigantic [ __ ] i was like
dog this guy i'm pretty sure he went to
prison at a certain time that's quite
sweet to me but he was gonna [ __ ]
murder that dude and that's how they
broke up because that guy got scared of
her dad damn yeah that's good what a
piece of [ __ ] man yeah it sucks that
there's like people that are just
like the emotional abuse is the weird
one because it's like there's no there's
no marks it's just that it's like weird
you can't really it's kind of hard to
define
uh
what do you do you know but like i said
that crazy [ __ ] too because
sacramento is such a small town we heard
about what he was saying about her and
kind of spitting the whole story around
right and once again i wasn't there
personally to see any of their stuff but
i've known this girl since i was a kid
you know what i mean i've seen her with
a few different guys and none of this
has ever
come to life they either just split up
because it worked out and the people
that she broke up with that she's still
friends with because that's how dope she
is she's just cool and this [ __ ]
comes around and he's telling other
people that she was like verbally
abusive towards him and i'm like no
[ __ ] way dude he's an amber turd yeah
he is he's straight up male 1
domestic violence like you're an amber
dude jada pickett smith is probably so
happy this happened oh my god i forgot
about you she's so happy because she's
like she was getting it and then this
came out now everyone's on amber but and
she's like
and people are digging up old clips of
jada pinka smith yeah kind of being
super disrespectful towards will she's
so mean did you see the gift the gift
one there's a there's a video of like
will smith
will smith plan like some huge 40
year old it was her 40th birthday or
something he had like extravagant [ __ ]
he had like elephants he didn't have
elephants but you get what i'm saying
like he has like a cover strawberry
willy wonka factory like full comes out
there's a barrel roll dick out it's sick
like it was it was just amazing and he's
telling this it's like his son jada some
other lady and him and they're on i
don't know why they're always on tv
talking about their [ __ ] life like
anyone like why are you guys setting up
like a show
bro it's like it's hard
but whatever they're for some reason
talking about this [ __ ] it doesn't need
to be talked about at all like hey just
let's circle back to that we'll see
let's go back to that but anyways he's
going on about all this extravagant [ __ ]
and they're looking at him even the
other lady was looking at him kind of
like because he's excited and the other
lady's looking at him like what a
[ __ ] lame ass like as he's saying
this they're like uh like
and then he says he does this for her
and jada looks at him and goes it like
pulls him aside and she's like why would
you do this this is like the biggest
display of your ego ever and like just
crushes them and even in the video it's
like i'm crushed and they're all looking
at him like even his own [ __ ] like he's
pathetic and i was like
like it's it's sad it's sad
and he's still like bubbly talking about
how pathetic he is and it's just like
wow you you you're getting that's what
you're getting cucked out yeah he for
sure is getting gasoline every single
time like i feel really bad for him
especially by his own son first of all
what's his name again willow jaden
you know what my sister said today she
goes you ever notice how like they named
their kids after themselves jada and
then willow willow yeah and i was like
oh [ __ ] i never thought about it i never
i've never been anything like that uh
yeah why would you right who would do
that who would do something
but also it's like the fact that she did
the whole table talk right
and to i don't know what the i don't
know what their content is but for them
to put out like a talk between them and
saying yeah i'd be [ __ ] this guy
named august who happened to be
my kids like best friends i've known him
since he's been a little boy that's
great is that is that considered
grooming bro that's grooming that is
that's great
it's something creepy but that's the
here's the weird thing about that that i
mentioned
yeah
him and jaden now he can always be like
bro i [ __ ] your mom
any argument any argument to have he's
like bro i think that's why i don't hate
yourself well i [ __ ] your mom i [ __ ]
your mom damn it doggy stop
i always overlook the grooming thing
because if i mean listen i hate to say
this but if it was like a guy who did it
this would be like the biggest headline
but she literally groomed this mentally
unstable kid and she [ __ ] him and then
that's just whatever they had a
relationship it wasn't just whatever at
the time i don't know if you guys
remember this there was a i mean that i
saw on social media a bunch of like
women that were like yeah you do you
like do your thing like there was all
this praise yeah it was like i mean it's
that's not everybody but there was that
faction of people that were doing that
and it's like you guys are [ __ ]
losers and hypocrites dude also too as a
guy man i kind of was like lucky
oh yeah me too i think like guys that's
why i if i think about it now i think
when i think about it
i probably was thinking the same thing
in the sense of i wish i got the [ __ ]
jada pink smith yeah she's so [ __ ]
pretty i think even with the bald head i
what about what about jada pinkett and
the matrix
she was in the way she's she always
she's really old wait was she old now
she gets old at the end in the in the
latest uh
matrix film they aged with makeup you
guys saw that it was the worst film ever
pieces of it i saw the trailer and i was
like no [ __ ] way am i gonna watch it
it looked like a cw show
like arrow or something
whatever that does the one [ __ ] small
bill was better than that the worst clip
that came out that they found was uh
jaina she was doing an instagram story
or instagram live and she was talking
about their therapist about how much
they improved will in her life she goes
oh yeah it's like will can you tell us
how dr blah blah improved our life
and then will was kind of like hey like
i didn't you got to give me a heads up
before you do this like that's not okay
cuz that's some serious [ __ ] yeah and
she goes see what i got to deal with see
this see this [ __ ] and then she puts it
can you tell us how she improved our
life and he's clearly [ __ ]
uncomfortable he asked her to stop his
face is serious he goes listen
instagram's like my livelihood this is
how i work you got to give me a heads up
and you tell don't do this inside my
house yeah
whatever and it kind of goes i look like
you just woke up too
yeah wow catch them off guard do you
know who they sorry go ahead no were you
saying
do you guys know who that kevin samuel
dude is you ever seen that guy there's
like a it's like it's [ __ ] if you
want to just like get lost in a
hilarious rabbit hole uh it's this black
dude and i don't really know if he was
like a pastor or something but he has
this like youtube live or instagram live
show where people like call in like
women will call in or dudes and he gives
people advice but he's brutally honest
and he'll [ __ ] on people he's like you
think you're eight yeah he'll ask girls
to rate themselves he's like what do you
think you are and they'll be like you're
like i'm a 10 and he's like he'll just
start laughing like like you're like
he'll be like you're five on a good day
and but like and he's not
like some of it's harsh but dude that
should hurt my feelings yeah bro bro
it's
so funny dude because he's he's clever
too but anyways there was this lady that
was talking about the whole slap
incident and she's like has a kid and he
like for 30 minutes has this
conversation with this lady and talks
about how like because she was like
defending like she was like will should
have slapped him chris rock because he's
defending his woman and he was basically
like you're the kind of lady that gets
[ __ ] killed like you are
terrible like he's talking about for
like black men but like men in general
you know and he's like you guys and
you're raising a son like i hope he's
way smarter than you you're a [ __ ]
idiot and he just tells this lady that
but it's like it's
hilarious how he does it so i definitely
recommend you guys check it out some
people need to kind of hear that [ __ ]
but that's what i'm saying like they
don't
they kind of look at guys as this this
being that's supposed to constantly
protect them from everything right which
okay that's fine i think like i guess
traditionally as a man it's good to
stand up for your woman but there's a
time into place yeah because at that
point when he did that
nothing good came of this at all
whatsoever and also how he felt as a man
is directly correlated to how she treats
him yeah all this cuck talk would have
never happened if she could talk like
you know what i mean
it's like cock-a-doodle-doo all right i
could do it let's start a podcast called
yeah
wow but but even like uh
the last thing that i remember hearing
about jada pinkett and she kept talking
about how her true love was tupac bro
dog did you go to the tupac museum [ __ ]
that was out in hollywood
bro this full tupac had a what about
goddamn phone nevermind i was about to
read that poem but he had a poem that he
wrote for her there's like so basically
in in the in the exhibit they basically
photocopied every single page that he
had he had business ideas which was
hilarious he had scripts he had plans
just because it was like
no ingredients to the food it was just
food it'd be like it'll be like uh thug
life cafe
fried chicken green beans salad and then
no recipes
hey my mac dream that's a start somebody
gonna cook this [ __ ]
not me though
the names of these cafes were like that
so he uh cafe fire he had poetry written
for jaina because they were like high
school lovers or something right and
she's i've heard her videos say like oh
they've kissed once and they didn't like
it bro there was a point
that's her true love yeah there was a
poem where he literally wrote like you
make me come without [ __ ] or
something like that like you bring me to
ecstasy all this type of [ __ ] wait they
didn't even [ __ ] and that's her true
love that's what she says they must they
got it they had to i believe they're
abstinent dog i believe tupac was
abstinent doug you know i mean he wait
till marriage that's what i believe yeah
i don't think so but he had thug life on
his stomach
he was his his whole
life was very interesting his mother was
a very very well-known black panther
which is why you know she birthed him in
prison right yes he was legend she was
she was pregnant with him while she was
in prison he was dope too that's [ __ ]
his punishment as a kid is that whenever
he [ __ ] up his mom made him read books
fire so he would always have to read
books if he messed up and then she would
like walk him through why and that's why
he's very articulate so yeah the crazy
thing is that he's punished
the punishment that she gave him didn't
make him hate reading or writing it
actually made him fall in love with it
which is usually the opposite you know
like if your parents make you do
something that you hate you're going to
probably hate it for life but he fell in
love with with writing and poetry he was
like in art school and [ __ ]
yeah his whole story is very very weird
and everything was an acronym
you know what tupac stands for
to produce and create
fire
that's pretty tight i had no [ __ ]
idea that it was an acronym i don't know
that anything two-pack shacker dude
all these celebrities too but there's
also what's it now now we have what the
mike tyson and the the airplane incident
which was so [ __ ] crazy to me because
i religiously listened to mike tyson now
yeah and he's so peaceful now that guy
would [ __ ] ask for it that guy was a
i mean dude he's so peaceful but like
come on dog like how he's pushing his
buttons that dude's like a bear still
you know he's still like a lion well i
heard or i read that he gave him a photo
like they did a selfie together
everything was cool and that guy was
being egged on by his drunk friends and
he would not stop pestering him like i
heard he was like imitating mike tyson
too like what are you doing guy why the
[ __ ] do you get to treat people like
they're pieces of [ __ ] like you own them
that is mike tyson dude yeah all people
that you want to poke at i don't think
mike tyson would be the one and he's in
first class for a reason so you could
probably avoid all that [ __ ] you know
what i mean you watch that first clip of
him like talking in his ear that's all
that's all the footage you need to see
that guy deserved to be thrown off the
[ __ ] hey where were the stewardess
bro yeah what the [ __ ] were they doing
like how are you letting this dude just
talk to other passengers belligerently
drunk should they kick them out kick
them out of here bro hey where's the air
marshall dog
what's the point of every air marshall
talk to tyson that way he should have
shot him everybody was like okay all
good and not like a kill shot just right
in the leg just teach him a lesson yeah
i mean tourniquet it up and he's all
good because that guy obviously sucks or
he's just too drunk he should have not
been in that situation ever you can't
put mike tyson that situation i said he
also threw a water bottle in too
so afterwards did he lead with the water
bottle oh the guy threw a water bottle
and that was the last straw oh well yeah
dude come on and also it wasn't like he
was beating him up he was just like
showing him what the [ __ ] is up like he
was just he was he was just saying like
look these could be fists
you know he was just slapping him oh was
it he looked like he was open-handed he
was cracking that's what he says when he
beats tiff
these are just open hands you sound like
amber when i hit you yeah
it was open
was i hitting him was i slapping you
what was it i'm just showing you what's
up i'm just showing you try to show you
what your place is if you threw a water
bottle at me i'm gonna [ __ ] show you
what's up they did look like big brother
punches though they didn't like he
obviously he could have killed that guy
but he wasn't sure he was like they were
just kind of like a little like yeah
which i think legal 100
i think that guy
legal
i think you should be able to throw like
one hard body shot at somebody and if
they drop it's all good hey man yeah no
kicks all good no no head trauma like if
someone gets knocked out and hits their
head yeah that's bad but if you drop
somebody the body shot that's pretty
good we gotta change these laws man i
think i think like look obviously like
you can't have full-on anarchy people
just getting down in the streets but
there should be like you said yeah like
body shots 10 second bodies you would
love them you would love seattle
mutual combat yeah yeah they got down in
florida too bro
you could just kill a [ __ ]
they don't care he did he died
yeah i didn't know that until i saw a
video clip of these two guys scrapping
in front of a cop yeah and they had the
cop kind of watch it go sick hey we're
both mutual combat mutual combat let's
go and they scrapped it out one guy got
his ass beat and they just split it up
after which is pretty [ __ ] dope
pretty dope man pretty dope and then you
could also refuse like if the one guy
refuses to fight then it's like okay no
fighting then and then everyone knows
you're a [ __ ] but hey you don't get
your ass kicked and you go home i
i i was kind of shocked at how much they
could throw down they were literally
beating the [ __ ] up were they really and
the cop was just watching with popcorn
in the corner it's like oh still
i think in california under the right
circumstances you could tell the cop and
if the cop is there you'd be like hey
mutual combat i think they might let you
slide i think they might enact it if
it's like an lapd cop like a cop that
sees some [ __ ] i bet you they'd like if
you and you were like in an alley they
might be like all right
not like not like south pasadena
whatever they're gonna they're gonna
break that [ __ ] up how do you [ __ ]
get somebody so mad that's literally
high 24 7 and on shrooms
how how's that possible i think we saw
the blueprints such a dick dude the
progression of the video is so good too
because he's like so happy and like in
his ear like in the cuts to the guy like
are you [ __ ] whatever talking to his
buddy and then the next clip is just
just him getting his ass booked it's so
good if there's one person on the
internet that's like he didn't deserve
that they shouldn't they shouldn't i
don't know i haven't heard anything
about getting him getting uh charges
pressed against him but i hope nothing
happens yeah i wonder too like
i want to hear the conversation like
what was my you know because when i see
him on the rogan podcast i could you
could instantly see him tyson's face
when he gets serious and how [ __ ]
scary it is well even the couple months
before right it was the we talked about
it here at the comedy show the guy pulls
out a gun you see mike tyson that video
doesn't even [ __ ] flinch oh that's
remembering he doesn't even [ __ ] this
dude's stoic as [ __ ] and even while this
guy was like talking in his ear you
could tell mike tyson is like trying to
zone out and be like ignore this
[ __ ] ignore him ignore him he
was definitely pushing his butt and that
guy was like belligerently drunk but at
the same time this [ __ ] was like
he knew exactly what we wanted to do he
was like this is totally okay with me
and i'll accept the consequences i'm
sure he was like i'll take i'll pay
whatever fine i have to do whatever
community service i have to do if i
could just slap this dude in the face
really quick that's that video of his
face where they zoom in on him and he's
like
like that's not about a movie like what
is this bro like yeah
it's like a social experiment somebody's
like putting a gun on mike tyson and
he'd even flip out so how annoying could
this guy be
yeah think about that sure it is that's
the answer
and that's that's the reason why this
guy should go to jail for at least six
months i'm pretty sure if a guy pulled
out a gun on me i'd be screaming dude
i'm running out the [ __ ] dog there's
no way i'm just coming up here i need
you to just relax just calm down i need
you to praise be to allah yeah
yeah
yeah the great son doesn't believe in
this violence yo i swear to god i'm like
no
no they create sun tzu that's really
good bro i listen to a lot of mike tyson
dude i could tell
i got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] man like 40 minutes is nonsense but
then randomly he'll say something hella
smart why make you want to be wise
does he make you want to do mushrooms
no
i saw this full uh on a what's it called
the white boy logan paul oh he ate the
[ __ ] handful of mushrooms it was like
fine stems or some [ __ ] and just shoved
it in his mouth and he's talking and
yes no i just
i don't see whatever you tell them give
me man
hey man [ __ ] chew that [ __ ] and
swallow it and then out of nowhere they
bring him a pigeon and this fool's
tripping the [ __ ] out he goes whoa this
is such a rest piece he's a
his eyes are super wide oh this was high
as [ __ ] he doesn't know where he's at
right now dude you don't know how much i
love pigeons it's great
if i close my eyes it's mike tyson bro
that's how good your impression is the
first time i ever had sex it was it was
ethereal
i i lifted into the air i started
[ __ ] my own dead mother it was crazy
and that's actual quote bro yes mike
tyson is the best dude he really is dude
he's such a unique [ __ ] person
there'll never be another dude like that
dude he's very well read too so he knows
a lot of like random philosophers he's
quoting them all the time i forgot what
he said to on he was on the rogan
podcast talking about um usyk versus the
possibility of usic versus uh
tyson fury yeah and he just uses random
analogy he goes boxing it's like a
nuclear bomb it's devastating but it has
to hit his target to be effective and
i'm like bars oh what's that bar
looks like this is some crazy ass
analogy that's [ __ ] dope dude yeah
that guy he's a jam dude he really is
teddy atlas too teddy ellis is the [ __ ]
he's another guy him because they all
were with custom auto and customized was
like yoda basically and very into like
the spiritual aspect of fighting and
like you could see that that blood on
the mike tyson and teddy atlas you told
me he used to
hypnotize mike so customary used to hit
like he was like 14 he lived with
customarto and so they would train
obviously he's first of all he would
make him watch tape all the time like
tyson just watched tape of the greatest
fighters all the time train all day
lived with them and then he would
hypnotize him and like basically sounds
kind of sus but
i like it when he would hypnotize him
and he would
tell him like he talks about joe rogan's
podcast and like basically tell him like
you're a conqueror you're a you're a
beast you cannot be beaten like just
like you're an animal that's dope and
and mike tyson when he's talking he
starts getting choked up he's like dude
he like on a subconscious level made me
a [ __ ] destroyer
and that's why he had so much like
self-belief and he forgot to snap him
out of it before he died and [ __ ]
yeah and then he died because like i was
supposed to do something and i can't
really
[Music]
like just over here just i was picture
mike just eating cereal hella angry [ __ ]
i'm a conqueror these fruity loops don't
have anything on me
yeah but damn bro
this was [ __ ] nuts yeah you're gonna
snap him out of here bro he's still in
that same trance yeah that's why you
beat that dude's house on a plane dude
that's what he gets
he had henry cejudo on his podcast a lot
and for like a for a bit on the house
when he did the one with uh habib oh i
never got to see it oh dude it's
hilarious because mike i think the story
was that mike got way too [ __ ] faded
before that episode so mike is just
sitting on in the corner
like not really talking much
and henry cejudo is pretty much doing
the whole interview with habib
and like the whole time like and there's
a one point where habib kind of like
he doesn't really talk [ __ ] but he talks
about how he who he says is the best
boxer of all time i think he he says
muhammad ali is better and he's like i
think muhammad ali is better than you
mike tyson i'm sorry like he says that
to him and he's just like blitzed out of
his mind doesn't really respond much but
there's like a sense of like tension
where i'm like oh this is kind of
this is kind of weird i don't know if
it's just me that feels that way but b
versus mike tyson who wins bro habib all
day brother all day now now yeah for
sure smesh back in the day back in the
day probably too yeah it's just tyson's
huge he has a skill set yeah yeah then
wrestling
yeah once he grabs you you're [ __ ]
hit but yeah true he's the goat for a
reason right do you think if habib came
back now he'd still smash that whole
division
i think
i think it would be a little
oh actually i don't know because i feel
like he was just getting started bro
like i feel like i don't even think we
saw a peak habib yeah i really don't i
think we saw like
a little bit more
like wrinkles to his game later in his
career
and like his ability to finish fights
like that because he decided he wanted
to right
but
i don't know i really don't know like
charles oliveira
that's a great fight because he's his
submission game is insane we're gonna
see
like the next evolution of that
with islam probably and uh charles
oliveira because if you think about it
charles oliveira is like tony ferguson
2.0
like similar skill set but just
better attributes better yes way more
refined like you look at charles
oliver's run dude he's on like a 15
fight 16 fight win streak all finishes
it's crazy because in his earlier career
he was losing yeah he [ __ ] up yeah he
would win a couple lose lose lose win a
couple of dollars he had to grow into
the sport i think like i think he got
thrown in the lion's den he had really
tough matchups and i think he was kind
of figuring out his style as he went on
but he just kept getting better
he became a way better finisher i think
he just
just fine-tuned his uh his approach to
the the game and i think it shows
because his muay thai like he could
knock you out he could [ __ ] take your
[ __ ] back and choke you out he could
leg lock you in the craziest submissions
you could ever see like he's just
he's so well-rounded now yeah so he's
going to give everybody a problem justin
gaichi or oliveira that's tough that's a
tough fight man i'd be thinking about
that in the shower i kind of think
if i had a bet i think i would bet gaiji
if i like had to bet yeah they're like
you must pick mexican pride dude mexican
pride if i had to bet i think i would go
aloe vera just because on
his ability to finish fights and where
he could do that because we we we all
know they're they're kind of each
other's kryptonite you know
like
we know gaichi can get subbed like
that's the most vulnerable we've ever
seen is him on his back and in
submissions like that's probably the
most vulnerable we've seen him and then
for oliveira i think the pressure of
gaichi and his low kicks and just his
hard punching style i think is going to
give a lot of problems with charles
libera but i think
i think the striking gap is close enough
where
if he gets a hold of him and he can get
to his back or get to a dominant
submission position i think he can
finish him i just went back and i
watched habib versus gaichi again even
though geichi was really really frantic
he had crazy shots on he landed heavy
shots heavy ass like not even just the
low kicks his hands yeah and then just
habit just didn't feel it which is so
weird it's the pres i think it's the
mentality there was a flush shot to his
temple from a classic gaichi hook and he
wobbled for a second and then he was
fine yeah that doesn't make any sense
like i don't understand how you can get
hit in the temple with a gaichi hook to
the head and he just goes okay brother
and he just starts marching down like
ran through him almost like sprinted
into
i think what the issue is is that like
no point in time in that fight did
geichi get his feet under him yeah
constantly moving back right he was
exhausted after the first round i think
lesser guys would have felt that shot
and would have wobbled but because of
that pressure and i think the size of
hobie definitely makes a big difference
too yeah but when you have when you get
that pressure and the whole time you're
thinking oh [ __ ] he's gonna shoot any
second now
i think that really puts
like uh it's really hard for you to land
those big shots that you're looking for
especially that like for a guy like
gaichi to habib so yeah you're right
especially with your feet planted too
you know pressure he's just kind of
throwing but like moving i think habib
said too his legs were kind of [ __ ] up
after he said that that that would come
out okay were the hardest shots he's
ever felt was from gaichi's kicks
but he looked fine yeah but he said that
was the hardest shot maybe he was such
an animal bro such an animal he still
trains like he's gonna fight which is
weird like you know most people you know
after they they stop fighting they'll
kind of take their time into you know
look at all their accomplishments maybe
eat a little food and relax but he
doesn't look fat he just looks buff yeah
he looks huge jacked he got bigger but
i think that's what you get when you get
a guy that's been so disciplined since
he was like five years old and all he
did was just
live eat train that's all he did so i
feel like for him he probably needs that
in his day-to-day or he's gonna go
[ __ ] nuts yeah you know he's like a
monk almost yeah honestly he was talking
about how i mean he was
i don't think he was joking either he
said that he doesn't believe in like fat
coaches he goes if you're going to be
training people you need to be just as
fit as them 100
which is kind of i was like oh i don't
see that a lot i think he was also kind
of throwing [ __ ] at dc
and javier mendez bro yeah he was trying
shots like look at these guys like
they're not they're fast he was saying
that now i felt like he was talking to
me i was like [ __ ] i gotta start getting
into work bruh
he's crazy he's the coach that could
[ __ ] up his fighters though yeah like
how often do you ever see that it's like
your coach is going to [ __ ] you up and
he's even bigger now he's like all i do
is run
grapple lift and i'm like that's the
life right have you seen the these um
the stuff that habib uses a lot which is
a little bands yeah what are what is
that i think it's just for
i have no idea i have no idea what the
russian wrestlers use russian [ __ ] yeah
but they use it for like judo warm-ups
like and just for kind of movement and i
think it's just like a
it's like a way better version of like
battle ropes they're like elastic bands
is that what it is and they're using it
for snap downs like just drilling those
basic fundamental wrestling movements
that they they're really good at and
there's using that to apply it to learn
how to wrestle let's get some bro we're
going to start wrestling bro your your
garage is dagger stand now let's let's
learn how to wrestle like no more
kickboxing right let's do it seriously
that's what i want to do bro i just want
to grapple dog we're kickboxing
yesterday i was like this [ __ ] sucks
dude this is so exhausting my [ __ ]
obliques are all sore and [ __ ] my
[ __ ] calves hurt nothing nothing is
more exhausting than just straight
wrestling though it's true let me tell
you it really is it's so tiring it's so
like you have to be in like college
wrestlers
they're in the best shape there's a
reason why they're [ __ ] shredded
and they're jacked as [ __ ] because
they're so [ __ ] physically strong
they have to
like you do a three minute just
wrestling round you're laying on the
floor i had a buddy um named sam in high
school he was like in our wrestling team
and then a b he was a b-boy as well and
a b-boy jam this is sick huh so there
was a guy who's like a bjj dude i don't
know anything about
bjj now but he was a blue belt and i
don't know what blue belt meant at the
time but
he was a blue belt and he was talking
[ __ ] to sam but sam was sam has farm boy
strength like he grabs your wrist you're
like you shouldn't be the strong yeah
you're hurting my tendons let go you
know this [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out
of this dude right because he was
talking mad [ __ ] he goes [ __ ]
wrestlers ain't [ __ ] you know bj i'll
choke your ass out
and now that i look back at it it was
just so fast how he fast he took his
double a and he slammed him and it was
just done that was it it was it that was
it that's the thing about jitsu right is
like a lot of these like especially the
evolution of the sport it was like the
gentle art like technique over strength
technique over size like that was
what the whole thing was about jiu jitsu
which is really important but once these
wrestlers start learning how to do jiu
jitsu yeah and you're starting to see it
like guys like nikki rod bro you look at
this dude he's like what six three he
could do a backflip standing like
nothing you know testicles like the
[ __ ] steroids yeah like just he's a
he's a crazy wrestler
you know what's a great example of this
actually um mackenzie dern not being
able to close that distance because she
has zero [ __ ] grappling dude she
cannot get in it was her last fight yeah
she won and her jiu-jitsu was amazing
yeah but how quickly could she have
ended that if she just learned how to
wrestle and and that's what the
dagestani guys are right like they're
the evolution of that like you watch
i've been talking about umar and
magamettov which is habib's little
cousin who fights at 135. the kicker
the kicker with [ __ ] dagestani
wrestling wrestling and finishing
ability yeah you know what i mean like
you take a guy like colby covington
great wrestler great mma grappler right
but at the same time he doesn't really
have any submissions like we haven't
really seen him in positions where
like you could take someone's back and
choke a guy out like he could hold you
there and beat you you beat your ass all
the time which is great but where's the
submission ability right that's the next
level and that's what like habib is
really good at that's what islam is
really good wrestling but also can can
do submission wrestling like nothing
choke you out choke you out he'll hook
you [ __ ] slam you on your head
however you want it and i think that's
the evolution and that's why the dagger
standing guys are so impressive because
they could wrestle their strong as [ __ ]
and they could submit you in any
position they want also to like these um
i think the viewership is getting a
little bit smarter to grappling because
before they would just boo them so much
it would deter these wrestlers to go
back to the foundation that makes them
so good but that weird little we are now
in this like
uh part in the ufc or just mixed martial
arts in general where they're bridging
that gap between striking and wrestling
where now it's flowing it's not strike
strike strike maybe i'll go for this
double leg everything sets up this now
and it's just so fluid so when you don't
see it like for example mackenzie dern
in her last fight it was frustrating for
me i'm like
you she's trying to grab her so hard
with these shitty strikes and these
terrible transitions yeah and you know
listen it kind of reminds me carla spars
a little bit she's a little disconnected
with her with her wrestling and her
striking which i think she's getting
better now yeah but watching mckenzie
durham do that i was like dude just go
to [ __ ] dagger stand for three months
and then just bridge that gap and then
you'll be choking [ __ ] out left and
right right nonstop i just want her to
go there yeah and then she'll pick up
the [ __ ] pakistani accent
she would dude i mean she switched up
her accent either way she'll go over
there she goes brother i don't
understand brother
they have this thing called micro
needling well they'll uh micro needle
your face and it causes like the surface
to be damaged so years ago i don't okay
i only know this random [ __ ] always so
years ago
[Music]
um there was uh they found this out
because people who are going bald like
there's no real like cure for baldness
right
but there's this new technique called
micro needling where they actually
damage the surface of your skin on your
scalp which causes
that irritation or damage causes hair to
grow back and they found this out
correct me if i'm wrong you guys can
look it up it was from somebody who was
a burn victim like he he was a burn
broken and his his scalp got burned
where he was
previously already bald and the parts
where it burned his hair grew back oh
and so they found out that damaging the
skin actually causes like your follicles
to either reactivate or something else
like that that causes hair growth so wow
there's a company who does a similar
thing to your face where you microneedle
your face and then it causes your hair
to grow
we're gonna get you on that dude i'm
gonna get something get that chin strap
now i don't even wanna get grow facial
hair bro do you even have hair on your
legs i just you know what's funny hello
hair on your lips hey bro my hair my
hair has grown thicker over the past
like two years and i got some hair it
used to stop like mid-shin now got some
hair on my kneecaps oh yeah dude so what
kind of a round of applause you're
pretty [ __ ] hairless though dude i'm
like a dolphin dude
like you're pretty [ __ ] hairless i
have no chest hair no nothing no body
here i have no chest i think i've got
some chester you have pubes
oh bro of course not okay hey bro
bro well i'm still waiting for the jesus
bro all right ham [ __ ]
gone gone because it's premeditated
pre-meditating everything you see here
pre-meditate
yeah but like yeah i got ball here bro
it's disrespectful first off let me see
your pubes nah dude it's a mess it's a
mess down there
i gotta clean it up it's like jumanji
knowing that the house gets crazy jungle
take over that's what's going on i gotta
i gotta i gotta it's a mess i gotta
clean it up she tried cleaning up with
flames dude i've been seeing those
videos where they do haircuts with with
fire no way no have you seen that [ __ ]
nah
they'll light your hair and then they'll
take the fire out but it'll it'll cut
your hair that sounds [ __ ] horrible
dangerous as [ __ ] it sounds smelly too
yeah it's like [ __ ] burning my hair
smells terrible like ass
yeah it's i got they do this
i i don't know i saw a couple of videos
because i used to watch these indian
head massage videos
those are cool though i don't think i've
ever seen one of those they brought the
[ __ ] out of you don't they this is the
funniest thing i've ever seen in my life
they literally slap the [ __ ] out of the
upside of your head and it's supposed to
be relaxing okay literally just
[Music]
and then just like and the guy is over
here getting head trauma the whole time
[Music]
the internet is [ __ ] common
afterwards
i've been watching that and i also watch
uh what's it called chiropractic
backcracks to help me sleep i help you
sleep yeah it helps me wow okay yep i'm
weird sorry
you know what i got in my uh my youtube
shorts algorithm recently when i feel
like a total [ __ ] virgin but it was a
it was like how magic tricks are
like they show them the magic of magic
tricks the tricks like the the how they
do it like how they do it and yeah but
it's like once you find out what it is
you're like this is so [ __ ] lame like
this is all it is they did a guy on like
america's [ __ ] home video whatever
the [ __ ] that those game shows that
people love
america's got talent or some [ __ ] this
guy has he he blows up some fire in his
hand and then pulls out a dove and
they're like how did he pull out this
dove out of thin air and it's like
there's a sleeve and he pulls it out of
the sleeve and i i was like so
disappointed like that's all it is yeah
i don't want to know the magic behind
magic that it ruins it really why would
you make these videos you [ __ ] yeah
you're ruining it it's the content game
baby by the way i hate magicians yeah
just in general [ __ ] them they are weird
what about [ __ ] limb you got beef with
shin limp
who the [ __ ] is that he's the guy that
does the vegas show he's like really
popular asian dude like chris angel
really well if he's probably
i don't know but everyone says he's
amazing but you know who also says that
gilbert gilbert loves magic and he says
gilbert looks like he would love magic
dude
[ __ ] magic the gathering [ __ ]
gilbert would love magic dude you're
almost the guy that just shows up at a
particle you guys want to see some magic
he said he used to do it in high school
and then like he makes a joke but he's
like that's why i didn't have sex with
anybody
that was his big tribute
let me correct myself i don't hate magic
i think magic is cool in appropriate
times like david blaine yes i hate it
when somebody just out of nowhere like
we're having a conversation no no no and
they're just like hey guys you guys want
to see a magic trick nope
[ __ ] you yeah i'm trying to talk to this
girl what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
hey pick a card yeah this card says get
the [ __ ] out of my face how about that
at all times if anyone ever says do you
want to see a magic trick you're being a
piece of [ __ ] you know what
the problem is you guys hang out with
people that do magic tricks that's what
the real problem is no that's no i don't
that's what's even worse about it i
don't even know you who are intrusive i
don't know these people if i knew
somebody i'd be i'd ask them yo show me
a trick but they come up to you out of
nowhere that's always been my experience
too where it's like i don't even know
who you are grab my sleeve get the [ __ ]
away from me what is your name like
let's introduce ourselves first guys
crap my sleeve gravity he just comes
okay thank you
great trick dude thanks that's a david
blaine trick dude that guy just knew
that comes all the time he doesn't fire
do you love me no are you sure and then
come comes out your mouth blew up
then why do you have come out your mouth
yeah i don't know about magic man yeah
magic's a little weird because people
love the magic castle
i went to the magic castle i hated it
did you so what's the hybrid why why do
people love us is it because it's
invitation only is that invitation only
you have to get invited and then there's
magic shows in there and half the people
in there are magicians and they'll come
up to you and they'll constantly ask you
if you want to see some magic
what are you saying no uh i had i did
say no and you could tell a little bit
of the spirit died
like like you could tell like their
heart broke a little bit and it made me
feel so good they never hit you
do they ever hit you with like a are you
sure
are you sure so i actually have pictures
because marielle had a co-worker who was
a magician yeah right very nice guy very
nice guy but it sounds like you're about
to [ __ ] on him
no no no no no
i don't do that brother brother brother
but she asked me oh do you want to go to
magic castle you could bring your
boyfriend at the time and in my mind i
was like [ __ ] go yourself well i want
to do this [ __ ] but of course i went and
you by the way you have to dress in a
suit you can't go there in normal
clothes they have a nice dinner there
though they do not okay and so you go
there and then there's just a bunch of
people you don't know who's a magician
or not so they're basically jumping you
with magic
it's like it's a magic gang bang right
it is dude and you're the [ __ ] middle
like you take one step and the guy goes
pick any card any card and i'm like all
right cool i'll pick this card was this
your card i'm like yes magic and then he
walks away wow and then i walked too
it's like that elementary as far as like
some of the tricks yeah and then i'll
walk over and the guy will be like okay
um you want to see some magic i'm like
dude i just saw magic two seconds ago
give me a [ __ ] break yeah even boxing
rounds there's twelve
in between
please
give me a prank dog
i just saw this guy show me a trick so
magic magic magic magic magic magic then
you do a show you watch more magic and
then you do another show there's more
magic and i'm like this place sounds
like a nightmare for you man it was yeah
yeah and then guess what i we got into a
fight
because i told she asked me what i
thought about the show and at the time i
didn't white lie i just
just said how i felt all the time oh
yeah and i found out that you should
learn how to white lie every now and
then to you know be mindful of people's
feelings she was the one who taught me
this and so she goes did you like it i
was like i hated it it was the worst
experience of my life oh and so she was
thoroughly upset yeah and she goes well
i thought you would have a good time i
was like you didn't even ask me if i'm
like magic it's my worst nightmare
and you took me to magic castle
and in her mind she was like saying i
did something nice for you i was like
yeah but you're doing something nice for
me that i don't like yeah so you thought
it was nice all you had to do was ask do
i like magic she goes well
why did you go and i'm like i went
because i thought it would make you
happy and i the experience of just going
and watching you be happy is good enough
for me oh man that's very romantic right
so if you're if you're enjoying this i'm
not gonna sit there and pout and she
goes well you just lied you pretended
like you enjoyed the whole thing it's
like what am i gonna do just go there
and be like hey
you are the biggest virgin i've ever met
get away from me no no i'm gonna do this
pick a card i'm like well yeah it's my
car wow
and i'm gonna go to the next guy he's
like you want to see fire he pulls out a
dove out of his sleeve i'm like oh my
god
you know animal abuse whatever yeah
that's what i thought yeah you hit this
[ __ ] dove in your sleeve for six
hours the dove comes out it's just
barely [ __ ] flapping his wings only
flaps one wing and [ __ ]
so like that was like the lesson i was
just trying to tell her like i don't
have to like everything that you do but
i know if it makes you happy i i will
keep my opinions to myself and i'll just
do it but if you ask me if i enjoyed it
i'm going to be honest saying no it
wasn't my favorite thing
but she hated the fact that i said that
yeah so now i just told her i'll just do
things if it makes you happy and if it's
important to you i'll do it
that's very nice you man this growth
happy ending again kind of huh yeah no
she was still mad oh no a few years ago
for a few years yeah
she's got it now yeah she gets it do i
want to go to the magic castle with you
i feel like that'd be so fun we should
just take a field trip with you
dog you'd be like this fool is pissed
the whole time just uh he's gonna roll
his eyes every time every trick you want
to see magic with the because chords
are the little red balls or the [ __ ]
fake thumb oh come on i'll tell you
something the red ball trick the red
ball annoys me the most yeah i was like
[Music]
six balls
there's always a big one at the end yeah
and then they go red ball wow and
everybody's just like this and i'm
sitting there like it's a foam ball bro
you're crushing it i get it i know where
it's at it's inside the tip of your dick
you [ __ ] now get the [ __ ] out of my
face man see if they did magic and they
you could like steal things from people
that's good magic
like if i could like take some of your
pocket is this your phone like whoa like
that's impressive the pickpocket [ __ ] is
the dopest kind of fire bro yeah i heard
there was pickpocket [ __ ] at magic
castle is that true or no no because
somebody stole my [ __ ] somebody would
have got these hats
your local community doesn't understand
where he's at i just start [ __ ]
people up so let's go about watch
it's a magic trick
[ __ ] these guys anyways that's this
episode shout out to the magic castle
bro no but anyway shin lim i don't know
who you are but if you did magic in
front of me i probably would really
enjoy it because most likely it's for in
the right setting he got the vegas show
like he's like the biggest headline if
it's a magic show and i'm there for a
magic show i'm going to enjoy it i think
that'd be tight yeah i think that's
that's the highest level of magic that i
have yeah shout out to lynn shim [ __ ]
yeah yeah
what what
shin lim oh shin lim that's what i said
he said it right he said lim shim did i
mean you just said that i thought you
said that no i just got out of the chat
i thought he was just being i thought i
was making funny that made me i wasn't i
had a little uh brain fart there
that's right that's what his new name is
local asian comedian racially abuses
another asian
classic davidson yeah
hell yeah dude let's get it
make my self-esteem disappear
there's a lot of magicians that are
gonna [ __ ] hate me uh you can follow
pat at patrick.t.riley
right check out his instagram he's a
stand-up comedian just making jokes all
the time making people laugh and you can
find nick at nick the ear
n t
e strong as they say and he yeah you
could catch him on jk news
you could also see him in these streets
with these hands dude yeah come come
train with us dude yeah
i dare you he's just going to beat you
up constantly i'm going to do that and i
just sit there and watch that's like my
favorite thing is hey you two spar
fight for me king of the castle fight
for me
the genius plays every sunday at 12 p.m
we'll see you all next time